Joseph please and who is this oh is this
right here this is my 12 year old
daughter who I raised all by myself
without the help of anybody else in the
entire world she is my inspiration
Joseph it doesn't matter there's nothing
you can do or say that's going to make
us change our minds today now right
there that right there that's her
daughter she blind come on
[Applause]
so I raised them both by myself without
nobody else's help come get your ticket
to Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
our love is here to stay each and every
day we know that we will never part
[Music]
wow great work everybody Troy I love
that little Motown outro thing super
Soulful cool thanks Lyle yeah just uh
came to me so I went with it wow
crazy hey is this uh one of the acapella
group mates oh hey Mark hey Lyle what's
going on buddy Mark get over here guys
this is my buddy Mark he just
transferred from Minnesota I thought he
could uh sit in on a few practices I
don't know maybe join the group or maybe
all right guys let's do always then my
girl again from the top
Mark show us your stuff you got it man
all right guys ready one two three
[Music]
each and every day
this world gosh okay well hey I just it
just came to me so I just went with it
great well keep going with it guys have
a safe weekend all right see you on
Monday nice to meet you guys man yeah
that was awesome isn't he the best food
guys great practice good effort all
right
[Music]
yeah check you later guys see you later
alligators
foreign
I'm doing my thing
this is my seven white boys
you need to back the
uh
that
I'm about to get mine
I don't have any idea how long it took
for me to infiltrate this girl
in five minutes
you think I'm gonna roll over or some
falsetto ass mom
no one
white boys is going too
but white boys is going to do
and if they want to run with a high-ass
singing falsetto
then that's on them
well that's on that man oh that's so
near me so it's like that always stole
like that well watch your back
we might
oh
[Music]
and improvise oh it's so cold out it's
gonna be dark soon oh my God yeah we
should build a fire oh yeah yeah
um oh I can't uh
hey man why the cat gotta be black
Grease
man I guess I gotta put my dick away
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so glad we could bring this project to
this neighborhood oh it's so rich in
history yeah I grew up in a neighborhood
like this oh yeah I grew up in a
neighborhood exactly like this
all right welcome to Mama's sugar bags
y'all ready to order yeah yeah can I
have a chicken fried steak with gravy
and a cola
I will have the baked beef short ribs
with collard greens and throw down some
of that cornbread all right babe
you know what
hold up a second I'm also going to have
some of the collard greens and cornbread
as well but hook a brother up with some
of them hot links all right all right
you know what uh why am I trying to
front scratch all that give me some okra
and some fried red snapper and girl you
know I want some chitlins all right now
y'all got ham hocks
colors well that's what I want I want to
play the ham hocks deep fried blackened
and served on a bed of mustard greens
pig feet
I want some pig feet and
and pounds of grits and oh oh and you
know what else give me a little Dixie
cup full of lard all right I just
remember what I want a bowl of
mosquitoes none of them tiny ones either
give me them big [__] to find
down at the swamp sister could you
please hook a brother up with a rusty
bucket full of fish heads wrapped in
razor wire donkey teeth donkey teeth
straight out a donkey's mouth you know
what okay any animal tooth will do I
want you to stick it in some honey glaze
fry it with fat back and serve it in an
old tin coffee can forget everything I
set up to this point right now bring me
some dandelion greens a cow hip and a
dog face wrap that whole mess in an old
Ebony magazine and serve it to me in a
shoe box okay I want to platter of stork
ankles an old Cellar Door a possum spine
and a human foot
you want a human foot
mm-hmm
I got just one question for y'all
you want gravy on that salad don't
oh definitely oh yeah yeah you got to
put gravy on it yeah without gravy it's
not food
hmm
it's really
um
[Music]
and Now ladies and gentlemen the man
you've been waiting for Mr Michael
Winslow don't get him Winslow
Bring the Noise
another sold out night for the kings of
mouth noise I tell you though we
wouldn't have this audience without
Winslow lucky for you huh it's Police
Academy fans look at all the t-shirts
six sequels can you believe it every
sound effect this guy makes is like a
little tiny Mona Lisa popping out of his
mouth and you ever heard him do
walking through the leaves in the
falling
[Music]
[Applause]
point
[Music]
s
what happened
[Music]
ting
Ling
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
laughs
we met b-boy Joseph in Atlanta GA hi
Joseph what's up
stop the music
[Music]
has he started
yeah I'm pretty sure this is it
[Music]
thank you
yeah thank you yeah are you done yet
though thank you Joseph it's it's
definitely a no for me it's a no I'm
sorry no
thank you Joseph thank you
because you know I ain't got no formal
training or nothing like that I learned
on the streets
that was very apparent as it turns out
Joseph thank you for coming you know my
mom is on drugs and my daddy in jail
it's not not really relevant born in a
coffee can under a bridge that's
terrible Joseph that's that's awful but
it's not going to my sister shot my
brother but my cousin beat my uncle okay
you know it's a little bit much Joseph
thank you very much but put myself
through school by renting my body out as
a heroin suitcase all right wow I see
what's going on Joseph please we do have
other dancers here today who are waiting
their turn very for lightly now Joseph
let her come on stage let her come no
Joseph if I won this competition I could
put a roof over my house because I got a
house ain't got no roof for real though
Joseph just one little thing though
don't do it Joseph it was a loud Bridge
don't finish that I got hearing damage
in this ear Joseph and also in this area
the bridge have trucks go over it just
because the bridge keep it 15 ton hold
it
put it in your mouth
and get off my stage rated six Joe
that's a big truck Seth okay Joseph
please and who is this oh who is this
right here this is my 12 year old
daughter who I raised all by myself
without the help of anybody else in the
entire world she is my inspiration
Joseph it doesn't matter there's nothing
you can do or say that's going to make
us change our minds today now right
there that right there that's her
daughter she blind come on
[Applause]
so I'll raise them both by myself
without nobody else's help come get your
ticket to Vegas
oh